when you got to yahoo three years ago
what were some of the problems and
opportunities that you were able to see
through the lens of somebody who had
spent so much time and product and the
lens of a computer scientist that
perhaps your predecessors weren't able
to see well I think that you know talked
with the fact that working at Yahoo is
this is the most amazing design problem
I've ever gotten to work on and actually
in thinking about today I think that
when you're doing a start-up and you're
building a company it's a design problem
but in a transformation and Renaissance
which is what we're trying to affect it
yahoo it is an engineering problem and
design and engineering are obviously
very closely linked but really looking
at the organization and try understand
what are the lever points what can where
can we get growth moving again what in
the organization isn't working as well
as it needs to it needs to be
re-engineered and it's so funny because
everything from our people our product
so how we look at our traffic and her
revenue to me well I look at them I see
engineering problems and we prototype
and we run things in parallel and we
don't scale until we know that they work
and all those basic engineering
principles they apply to everything from
the culture of the company to know how
we run our products and how we think
about our business lines so can you give
us a specific example of how you looked
at a business scenario whether it was an
acquisition or a people management issue
that you think really crystallizes and
reflects that engineering perspective
with specifics that people in this room
could potentially relate to sure well
for example I'll take a look at our
content strategy last year to me 2014
was our time to do a lot of different
experiments we experimented with some
partner content we experimented with
some live content with live nation we
had a lot of our editors in different
verticals work on their own series and
clips of what they wanted to work on we
did some original content and we
basically did each of those a really
small scale to understand what worked
well what did we think we produced with
quality whether our audience respond to
and
2015 returning to it we're really
looking and saying okay what we thought
work really well was the magazine
content the deep verticals that yahoo's
always been known for how can we build
out more video there how can we we're
gone more more on content so when we do
things like the ultimate DJ we're gonna
be running an American Idol like show
with Simon Cowell to find the best DJ in
the world next year that aligns really
deeply with Yahoo music the NFL
opportunity aligns really deeply with
Yahoo Sports and so I think that really
helped us shape our content experience
to think about let's run a bunch of
experiments build a bunch of different
prototypes see what works and what
really our users respond to and that's
things like live nation and some of the
verticals we've always been strong in
and then how do we build even more
content in that vein